what's the difference in flat space and
uh asymptotic decider space so flat
space is just an approximation of like
the world we live in so like uh uh the
sitter space at some time I wonder what
that even means meaning like
uh asymptotic over what okay so for
thousands of years
you know until the last half of the 20th
well sorry until the 20th century
um we thought space time was flat
can you elaborate on flat
what do we mean by flat
well like the surface of this table
is is flat let me just give an intuitive
explanation surface of the table is flat
but the surface of a basketball
is curved
so the universe itself
could be flat like the surface of a
table or it could be curved like a
basketball which actually has a positive
curvature and then there's another kind
of curvature called the negative
curvature
and curvature can be even weirder
because
that kind of curvature I've just
described is the curvature of space
but Einstein taught us that we really
live in a space-time continuum
so we can have curvature in a way that
mixes up space and time
and that's kind of hard to visualize
because you have to step what a couple
of Dimensions up so it's hard to you
have to step a couple but even a
if you have flat space and it's
expanding in time
you know we could imagine we're sitting
here this room good approximation is
flat but imagine we suddenly start
getting further and further apart then
space is flat
but it's expanding which means it's
space time is curved
ultimately it's about space time okay so
what's the what's the sitter an entity
Center space
the three simplest space times
our flat space time which we call
minkowski space time
and negatively curved space-time
anti-decider space
and positively curved space-time the
sitter space
and so astronomers
um think that
on large scales even though for
thousands of years we hadn't noticed it
beginning with Hubble
we started to notice that space time was
curved space is expanding in time means
that space time is curved
and the nature of this curvature is
affected by the matter in it
because matter itself
causes the curvature of space-time
but as it expands the matter gets more
and more diluted
and one might ask when it's all diluted
away
is space-time still curved
and astronomers believe they've done
precise enough measurements to determine
this
and they believe that the answer is yes
the universe is now expanding eventually
all the unit matter in it will be
uh expanded away but it will continue to
expand
because uh well they would call it the
dark energy Einstein would call it a
cosmological constant in any case that
the in the far future
matter will be expanded away and we'll
be left with empty decider space